Đanisa kết hợp cùng bảo tàng Andersin cho giá mắt bộ sư tập qua Trung Thu đặc Việt phy bản dưới hạn.
Mô trang giám hai không hai làm này, Danisa đang đến sự khác biệt và mới là bất ngờ với bộ sư tập Trung Thu phy bản dưới hạn mang tên Danisa Andersin.
Bởi thế kế được đau lấy cảm ứng từ chính những câu chuyện khu thích nổi tiếng của nhà văn Andersin,
năng tinh cá và của bè bà dìm. Mỗi hồ quà không chỉ là sự kết hợp tinh tế giữa vị bánh ký bơ chứ rằng mà còn làm một tóc phần việc thôi.
Kể lại những câu chuyện tội thơ đầy cảm giúp của gọi trọng hôm bị hoàn gia đàn mặt vừa nâm tầm giả chị bằng những câu chuyện của tích bất hồ.
Kết món quà trở thành cựu tượng của sự trân vui và tình cảm trên thành trong bộ đàn biệt.
Dưới hồ bản lựa trọng qua bánh chút tù, Danisa Andersin đã tạo nên bộ giấu ấn khác biệt.
Bất nả hôm bị bánh ký phòng gia đàn mạnh được ưa chủ, nhưng này, bơi thiết kế hồ quà xong trọng Danisa Andersin trở thành một món quà đàn cấp tinh tế và ý nghĩa.
Hồ quà phín bản của tích lên này của Danisa Andersin chính là một khoảng hành hàng để bạn bày tỏ lòng trên trọng và tình cảm xúc sắp đến những người thành yêu trong bộ tích chương tu sắp tới.
Hãy để Danisa cùng bản viết đến câu chuyện của tích trong bộ chupu năm nay.